I'm a TV junkie,
so I like pictures.
I like images and radio doesn't have
that.
Um,
which might initially seem weird,
but it's kind of a,
it's kind of ultimately the coolest
thing about radio is,
is what it lacks is somehow empowered by
it,
by the absence of pictures.
Because what that enables is the simple
act like I could describe something to
you,
you know,
um,
like when I walked up the stairs to come
into the studio,
you know,
the sun was out in the sun,
had this weird kind of pg white,
whew,
that was kind of like the color of a
fox,
his belly or something.
Like you may be just imagine something,
right?
Um,
well think of what,
just what just happened.
They're like,
in a sense I'm painting something,
but I'm not holding the paintbrush.
You are.
Um,
so it's this deep act of coauthor ship
and in that is some potential for
empathy.
I think it's somehow we're doing it
together because we have to fill this
gap of picture listeners together.
We have to somehow be connected.
I love that about radio as much as I
want.
I mean,
I've watched so much tv,
it's kind of shocking.
But I love the,
the immediacy and the connection that
you can have with another person through
radio.
And I think it has something to do with
this co imagining that happens.
If,
if I do my job right,
then you,
if I can put certain images and feelings
into your head,
then I know we can connect.
No matter what you do to it.
You,
no matter what you want,
new techniques you inject.
I mean,
the power of this medium is rooted in
the human voice and the human voice has
so much information in it,
the vibrations of the voice,
the way the voice rises and falls,
the musicality of the human voice is,
um,
the engine of everything that we do.
So perhaps that's why radio never dies.
It's supposed to have died about 50
times right now.
And I'm sure it'll be declared dead 50
more times.
But there's something that happens when
you turn on the radio and someone's
talking to you and they're talking to
just you.
And,
um,
there's an immediacy and a,
in a,
in an intimacy that can happen that,
um,
I kind of feel inoculates this,
this technology from ever dying
least.
I hope so.
That's my bet.
Professionally speaking.